siesta key the remainder of season four
season four b what are you most excited
for fans to see what happened with my
breakup because i
feel like i didn't really open up about
it much online which i think would be
immature to do and i'm past that age
where i go online and talk about other
people so oh you know and like my
ex-boyfriend sam did that a lot and a
lot of people have these opinions on our
breakup or what really happened and so
now they're gonna actually see the real
story amanda same question for you i
feel like i just change a lot and i know
i mean there's definitely some moments
where good old amanda comes out but i
feel like i am just moving more into my
career and more into like what's next
for me once i graduate but there's a lot
and it's exciting it's dramatic but we
had fun and this is why we do this yeah
so before i go into individual questions
um juliet i want to ask you on a scale
of one to ten
how wild are things getting in season
four b of siesta key
um i would say like a 9.6
bam that's close to 10. my gosh are you
guys really like blowing off the lid and
listen i've
i've had my fair share of some some wild
moments so at least i'm learning from
those but i think other people around us
are still pretty wild we have some
people that like don't know how to
control themselves some people that just
don't care about others they don't have
respect for others so you're gonna see
all of that happen amanda's had our
moments i've had my moments but we've
all had our moments that's
any drink throwing in season 4b
probably i'm just gonna say probably
there was like some
horrible moments so for me i'm just like
hold me back like amanda had to
literally hold me back juliet who's
testing you why is amanda holding you
back i can name five people but what's
what's like really
upsetting is like some people know that
their relevancy on the show is based off
pissing me off so
that's where you break the fourth wall a
little bit people are like if we go
after her this is gonna this is gonna be
on the show there's some some girls who
just really have no respect and they
don't mind causing drama and they don't
mind being
like
the center of drama and we're like okay
like give us your best shot we can
handle it all i promise amanda i also
want to ask you
one to ten how wild are things getting
this season on siesta cake being
realistic i'd have to say it's anywhere
between an eight and a nine it's up
there
definitely
there are some crazy moments and things
you guys won't expect so yes
okay
juliet i want to go to you first um
obviously um we ended the last season
with you and sam are moving in together
he throws you this huge you know jmp the
label party and it seems like the demise
of that relationship is really going to
be carried out through the episodes to
come i might need to move out i'm sorry
that i hurt you but am i sorry for doing
what i need to do for myself no what can
you tell us about the the breakup and
what went wrong sam and i just like came
from two different worlds and
our like our live our lifestyles just
weren't really fitting together and
we just wanted different things and i
think that he wanted me to live his life
and i didn't want that and um it
ultimately just caused so much tension
i just became really
emotionally worn down i you know and we
live together so there's no escape when
it comes to that because we would fight
every time we would go out i was unhappy
i was tired all the time so you can
really see like what
what
moments caused that throughout the show
because i mean as soon as we started
filming is when like the cracks really
started to show i'm way too independent
for him he's way too dependent for me it
just was never gonna work was there like
a final straw that you were like i'm
done here i was trying to make it work
by moving out like i was like okay maybe
we could save our relationship because
clearly we don't work together
and i think that just wasn't something
he was comfortable with like it was like
an ego thing he wasn't happy
with the fact that i couldn't live with
him anymore and then that was when
everything hit the fan and it was like
he couldn't handle it i did try to make
that relationship work and
now i'm happy it failed so
what is it like for you to have to
relive this you know painful chapter of
your life seeing someone that you you
were invested in as now these episodes
are about to air week by week is that
weird for you is that sad it's more just
a little surreal it's uncomfortable
going back and
reliving these moments that were
very vulnerable and very private it
doesn't feel private to us when the
cameras are watching but then you know
that behind that screen hundreds of
thousands of people are going to be
seeing this yeah well like you i know
you guys are not strangers to people
having opinions about your personal
lives and people talking about every
little moment on social media juliet i
want to do a little quick rumor patrol
with you for anybody out there who feels
like you used sam what is your response
to that if i only cared about what sam
had i'd still be with him right i would
have
lived the life that he wanted me to live
with him and any uh thoughts on these
cheating allegations we're hearing julia
cheated sam cheated have you seen what
sam's been posting she was doing exactly
what i was doing just hiding it and
lying about it so is it really over i
don't want to hate him
you guys will see
why but yeah he totally did
okay so you're saying he cheated you
didn't juliet's not a cheater i don't
know it's really the way you look at it
you're gonna have to decide yourself
what terms are you and sam on today how
do you guys stand um i don't talk to him
i don't see him i feel like another
dagger in the situation was just his
like intense ego problem and i hope that
like he took something away from
the everything that happened between us
and like hopefully learn something that
he can use again in a future
relationship listen i i want to talk
about something that makes me happy i
look at you on instagram and it seems
like you're just very smitten and you
have found a wonderful guy in your new
man clark drum clarkdrum
tell us about this new relationship with
clark he just like actually listens to
me he respects me
i respect him it's like a give and a
take kind of thing which is
which is really nice how did you guys
meet such a cute story um i was super
drunk with amanda and chloe and some of
our other friends it was like pouring
rain we're at a bar
and chloe takes my phone and she's like
we need to find you a new guy and she
like dms clark i like knew him from
friends of friends like i barely knew
him we were just like instagram friends
and so chloe messaged him from my
account
saying text me and he texts me in like
five seconds
it was so quick it was so fast it was
crazy how fast it was and then at the
drinkers that we are we're like let's go
to he lives in fort lauderdale we were
like let's go to fort lauderdale we'll
book an airbnb so we booked an airbnb
like all the girls so we could go meet
clark
and then the next day we woke up way too
hungover to go
so you're like sorry we're not coming
yeah
so how did you finally meet he invited
me to the bahamas like randomly like
like a couple weeks later
and i was like yeah yeah
casual first date right right so and and
you met for the first time on a trip
that you took together well you'll see
how we really met
yeah it'll play out okay so we will see
him on siesta key yeah yeah you'll yes
you will
yeah that's very exciting how serious
are things i mean could he be the one
he's definitely like
is everything i want
in a guy but there's no like rush for me
to settle down i'm young i want to
experience a lot of things now so that i
don't get that whole like mid-life
crisis thing happening in the future
with sam
he was always so angry when i would go
do things without him or go on go on
work trips and with clark he's like okay
have fun bye
so that's what's really important yeah
yeah um and then just sam being on the
show you being on the show clark being
on the show
are we gonna see the three of you in in
social settings together and that's so
weird it's so weird
very awkward very often it does happen
so is there is there a lot of drama
between the two between sam and clark
yeah
in general yeah
yeah
i think i think he died down a little
bit because
clark doesn't like feed into the drama
and which i love about him it's like
he's like this is like this is you guys
i'm not gonna get involved with your ex
okay well juliet i'm so happy that
you're that you are happy and you seem
to be in a really great relationship
amanda i want to transition over to you
um a little heartbreaking the end of
season 4a we kind of saw you and tate
kind of going in in complete opposite
directions where do we pick up with this
new batch of episodes yeah um we
definitely went very opposite directions
but i kind of
did a u-turn but not
towards him you'll see ah okay so there
there does seem to be a new man that is
being teased in your life what can you
tease
i'm happy right now and like julia said
i'm not in a rush to settle down and be
like super serious and like all about my
boyfriend and like trying to get married
and stuff and i just
want to be happy and
there are some
some people that make me happy so
is amanda a single woman or is amanda a
taken woman um i don't want to answer
that because i don't want to ruin it
listen if your smile says anything it
seems like you're pretty smitten with
whoever's lucky enough to have you in
their life i appreciate that yeah well
we'll see
i feel like this season like my friends
needed me a lot like juliet needed me
chloe needed me there was a lot going in
their lives and i just kind of wanted to
just be there and be supportive and
so yeah it's a lot of friendship stuff
too
well listen speaking of the word
friendship um i just want to have a
little moment for madison you know it
was so beautiful watching her
relationship with ish unfold and then
they announced in the season 4a finale
um that they were expecting a baby and
then just the worst tragedy i'm i my
heart goes out to both of them um for
you two as friends i'm curious how is
madison doing and how have you guys been
there to support her over the last few
months
there's we definitely filmed a little
bit for i mean obviously that happened
like out of nowhere nobody expected that
so there's definitely a little bit of
there
a little bit of that in there you know
she has days where she's so happy and
she loves i'm so thankful that she loves
talking about him we got to hear all
about her labor and what she went
through and like how she feels now so
everybody gets to see that and us just
supporting her as much as we can even
though there's not much we can do other
than just be there for her how is
madison doing today you know i'm so
amazed at
the beautiful way she's handled this
entire situation she's been going to
like grieving mother courses and stuff
like that and most importantly like she
wants people to talk about elliott and
how beautiful he is and you know and
share her
share her story as much as i don't want
to say i'm excited for people to see
this it's something that i'm
i i'm i think they need to see
it's been almost five years since siesta
key first came on the air i'm curious
amanda
how long do you plan to continue sharing
your life with the cameras i will keep
doing this as long as they want me
because there's just something about
watching yourself grow up on tv i hope
like one day when i have kids and stuff
i'll be like yeah look how cool your
mama is like
really
bombshell on mtv love it i mean i kind
of agree with amanda i always do get
kind of
i get like nervous i feel like i've just
been through like some like emotionally
traumatic things on camera and so like
even now with this new relationship i'm
like oh god it does you know the cameras
make it make relationships kind of
harder so i'm like i hope this one like
isn't affected by it
but i would like to keep doing it
forever i feel like you know it's i love
doing it i'm so used to it now and it's
just such a huge part of my life like i
don't know where i don't know where i
would have been at at this age without
siesta kids maybe we'll do like real
housewives of siesta key eventually yeah
five years from now juliette where do
you see yourself i want to be in a happy
relationship maybe starting a family i
want my business to be i want my
business to be just like it is right now
but much bigger i would be okay with
getting more into a serious relationship
and you know like i want to have kids in
my 30s and
so who knows what's gonna happen five
years of siesta key knowing what you
both know today about life about fame
about relationships about people
juliet what do you wish you had known
when you had started this whole siesta
key journey that you know now
if you think he's cheating he's probably
cheating
oh my god don't drink too much
violence isn't the answer
you are my friend you want to get your
happy too so the number one thing that i
learned is don't be so hard on yourself
and i
i love that little trick that's like if
it's not going to matter 10 years from
now don't let it don't let it matter 10
minutes from now okay next batch of
episodes in one adjective cringe
everything just makes me cringe i'm like
oh don't stop or like ew why was i with
him i love that i'm always like why did
i do that
okay cringe and amanda i feel like
unpredictable
because so many things happen that i
would have never imagined happening in a
million years
[Music]
you